hundreds if not thousands of
unemployment claimants are concerned
about
changes to their online portals joe
moeller is looking into a number of
issues he joins us now live at the deter
office in las vegas with those details
hi joe
yeah hey there a lot of people reported
these issues starting yesterday some
people were saying that
their history of claims is completely
wiped off of their portal others are
saying they're now being asked to
verify some more personal information
all of a sudden that benefits exhausted
changed to regular active which is what
it's supposed to be
jeffrey brown logged on to his
unemployment portal sunday and thought
his benefits were going to start
my benefit balance went from zero up to
over ten thousand dollars enough to
cover me to september which is from the
american rescue plan
surprised by this he checked again a
couple hours later
i went back in because i was just
thrilled i want to look at it
and it changed no more stimulus and now
my payment amount was zero
brown is not alone many claimants went
online and shared their frustrations
about a number of problems
then what we started to notice was that
people were
had their entire claims wiped clean
amber hansen runs a popular unemployment
facebook group she says there are a
number of issues
some are having previous claims wiped
out some are getting payment changes and
others are getting identification
notices
so it's like a giant mess because it
doesn't just seem to affect
one group of people it seems to affect
the commonality i think is those that
were exhausted in appeals
or were appealing something the people
are worried about missing payments
many are still waiting for dieter to
make changes to get paid for the extra
benefits being implemented by the latest
stimulus bill
she wonders if a system update is
playing a role it may have something to
do with an update but
this was the wrong way to go about it
now back out here live i did reach out
to dieter about these changes that
people are noticing they tell me they're
receiving a high
volume of uh people trying to call in
and get some answers to their questions
so they're still working on a reply for
me
dieter did send out a statement earlier
on twitter stating that
there will be changes for pool claimants
when it comes to filing their weekly
claims
and to follow the directions that are on
there they did not elaborate on these
changes that people were talking about
so obviously a lot of people still have
questions but
we'll be staying on top of the story and
we'll bring you the very latest
reporting live you're outside the dealer
office joe mohler 8 news now